on a l'impression quand quand ils on
parle que c'est vrai que c'est euhie en
bande organisée il y a quelqu'un
derrière vous je dis qui qui a une
voilà des personnes qui vous influencent
et qui essaent de de d'extorquer des
fonds à coé ça pour vous c'est euh
vraiment exclure c'est complètement faux
parce que pour pour dire moi je le le
samedi où j'ai été porté plainte c'est
je je l'ai fait je l'ai fait j'étais
même pas sûre d'aller porter plainte ce
jour-là c'est que je je je marchais dans
dans dans la rue et je me suis retrouvée
devant la porte de la gendarmerie et je
me suis dit c'est maintenant ou jamais
que tu le fais c'est-à-dire que je moi
je j'y suis allée j'avais pas d'avocat
quand je su je suis partie porter
plainte j'y suis allée j'y suis allée
comme ça et j'avais pas d'avocat bien
avant après la plainte j'en ai trouvé un
là maintenant qui a qui qui qui saura
défendre l'affaire mais sinon non donc
il y a pas d'extorsion de fond moi j'y
suis allé comme ça sans même savoir ce
qui allait m'attendre quand est-ce que
tu été en contact pour la dernière
dernière fois avec avec Sébastien cé cet
été cet été on on dit je te dis tout que
tu l'aurait proposé de le rejoindre
alors ça c'est c'est ce que Gill verdz
lui c'est lui c'est c'est ce que
l'entourage de Sébastien cohet m'avait
rapporté effectivement alors ça je vais
il y a encore les preuves parce que
heureusement que que je garde tout
absolument pas c'est lui qui m'a dit qu'
mixé dans le 38 d'accordo donc c'est
vous qui lu avz proposé de venir ou
c'est lui il il y av même pas une
intention de se rejoindre il m'a dit je
mixe dans le 38 je lui dis ah bon ça et
mais c'est là qu' m'envoie vers un plan
d'eau vers la vallée du plan d'au je
sais pourquoi non j'y suis pas allé ah
d'accord ah c'est le dernier comp non je
n'y suis pas allé d'accord et la
dernière fois que vous l'avez vu la
dernière fois que je l'ai vu bah c'était
en mars en mars pourquoi 2022 c'était
pour qu quelle occasion c'était les
faits d'accord les les fait les deuxièm
faits que vous relatez parce que c'est
c'est quoi les deuxièmes faits parce que
c'est vrai que on avait parlé que des
premiers faits la dernière fois c'est V
c'est quoi les les les les les deuxièm
faits
Julie bah les deuxièmes faits euh c'est
la même chose que que les premiers
finalement et euh c'estd vous vous voyez
où en fait alors on en fait on se
rejoint euh devant les studioos
d'énergie parce que j'étais sur Paris
pour un séminaire du travail on se
rejoint en fait sur vers le vers
ennergie 22 rue boilot
et c'est à ce moment-là que il me dit je
je te ramène à ton hôtel c'est mal c'est
mal fréquenté donc je monte dans sa
voiture et finalement je me retrouve
chez
lui d'accord là vous dites quoi vous lui
dites non j'ai envie de rentrer chez moi
ou mais vous dit bon on va prendre un
verre comment ça se passe bah je non il
propose pas de prendre un verre je lui
dis de simplement que je souhaite sortir
de la voiture il me dit de toute façon
pour remonter non faut un badge et c'est
à ce moment-là que
qui se repasse les mêmes faits je vais
pas les expliquer parce que ça
me ça me touche encore beaucoup et je me
sens encore vachement coupable donc je
veux pas trop en parler ça la justice c
sa lumière aussi vous sentez coupable j
parce que j'y suis
retourné ça coupable d'être revenu le le
voir d'être revenu d'avoir gardé ce
contact de parce qu'on a gardé on a on a
gardé malgré tout contact malgré tout
et c'est et c'est ça que les gens
arrivent pas à comprendre c'est ça
s'appelle l'emprise ça c'est ça
l'emprise c'est ça
l'emprise j'ai une question Julie vous
vous avez dit que ça ne vous étonnait
pas qu'il y ait d'autres plaintes parce
que des femmes des jeunes femmes avaient
pris contact avec vous sans doute sur
les réseaux sociaux pour apporter leurs
témoignages est-ce que vous avez reçu
des témoignages qui ressemblent au vôtes
qui ressemble au mien oui j'en ai reçu
j'en ai reçu après je peux pas parler à
leur place moi j'ai j'ai j'ai énormément
enfin énormément j'ai eu quand même
plusieurs plusieurs témoignages de de
jeunes femmes et les processus sont
toujours décrits de la même de la même
façon alors il y a pas eu forcément viol
mais ce quiessaie de de de de de de
décrire Julie c'est qu' a une espèce
d'emprise il y aurait une espèce
d'emprise qui fait que on se sent forcé
euh d'agir ainsi avec la menace de de
soit perdre son emploi de soit pas
pouvoir y parvenir dans dans dans le
milieu et cetera Guillaume oui il y a un
des avocats vous l'avez dit vous avez
consulté plusieurs avocats avant de
choisir le vôtre il y a un des avocats
qui dit que premièrement vous ne saviez
pas où il habitait au moment où vous
l'avez vu cet avocat et deuxièmement que
vous vous ariez posé la question à
l'avocat combien est-ce qu'on peut lui
prendre pour cette affaire est-ce que
c'est vrai ou pas c'est les propos de la
personne c'est pas et Ben qui donne le
nom de cet avocat que j'ai été voir
parce que les avocats ils sont déjà pas
médiatiques et j'en ai j'ai donné
absolument le nom à personne donc si
vraiment il l'a retrouvé ah mais moi je
l'ai eu je vais pas le dire parce que
voilà mais je moi c'est des propos que
j'ai recueilliis non mais de l'avocat
oui bah donner le nom de l'avocat c'est
maître je peux pas le donner parce que
c'est on pas citer nos sources non mais
je c'est maître non je vous dirai pas
qui mais je vous dis que j'ai eu un
avocat qui m'a dit ça mais je c'est une
femme c'est une femme ou c'est un homme
c'est un avocat c'est un homme c'est un
avocat tu peux dire c'est une femme ou
un homme c'est c'est un homme
et ben ça prouve que c'est complètement
faux puis que j'ai vu des femmes ah oui
bah ouais ouis c'est moi j'ai vu un mail
o vous l'avez contacté en disant bonjour
je souhaite mail oui j'ai pas échangé de
mail j'ai appelé directement j'appelle
que les avocats directement vous avez le
mail je fais le voir si parce que Jul je
crois qu'il m envoyé en photo mais je
l'ai vu de mes propres yeux mais c'est
une avocate que j'ai vu je vois que des
femmes donc jamais vous n'avez demandé
d'argent absolument jamais et ça j'en
suis certaine
parce que j'en veux pas vous voulez pas
c'est pas votre but c'est pas mon but
moi mon but aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir
me reconstruire et de pouvoir faire
entendre moi ma seule victoire ce serait
de vraiment être considéré comme une
victime et pouvoir m'en sortir parce que
je vous assure que d'être sous
antidépresseur on ressent plus rien on
vit plus en fait je suis à 300 mg par
jour c'est en fait on est on est comme
ça on est linéaire toute la
médiatisation de cette affaire euh et le
fait que qu' a porté plainte contre vous
est-ce que c'est vous vous dites quoi
vous dites vous le saviez vous redoutiez
ça vous saviez que ça allait prendre je
le je le redoutais pas parce que je me
je me suis jamais dit bah oui va avouer
tout de suite je me je me suis pas dit
oh bah oui il va il va y aller il va il
va s'avouer coupable pas du tout je le
savais que j'allais avoir une plainte de
lui je savais qu'il allait faire des
démentis et cetera après moi je j'ai
absolument tout en ma possession et la
justice a aussi les choses donc après
avoir avoir alors il y a la chaîne qui
dit bien sûr on peut pas montrer le mail
à l'écran ils ont pris pour des
pas dire le nom
deocc pr vraent pour desa c'est bien de
le savoir c'est important de savoir
qu'on est pris pour des con dans sa
propre chaîne ça fait toujours
plaisir pourquoi il y a des gens qui qui
disent que tu es pas clair sur ton âge
je dis je te pose toutes les questions
comme je t'avais dit qu'est-ce que tu
réponds à ces gour-l parce que tu dis
que la première fois que qu' a eu voilà
c'est ce drame dans la chambre d'hôtel
tu dis que tu avais 15 ans et il y a pas
mal de gens qui disent que c'est que en
fait tu avais pas 15 ans que tu montais
sur ton âge et cetera c'est ça Gile
aussi oui des approximations sur l'âge
ça on on en a parlé aussi ensemble
est-ce que vous pouvez remettre
effectivement je suis né en fin de je
suis né en fin d'année je suis né le en
septembre donc en fait la ma première
rencontre céta à 15 ans quand les faites
se sont passées j'avais 16 ans révolu
donc en fait ça c'est pareil sur la
plainte c'est c'est marqué ou c'est
marqué et sur les âges aussi je peux pas
mentir sur mon identité jus s prononcée
d'une certaine façon puisque elle a
rencontré cé à 15 ans mais la le premier
acte supposé aurait eu lieu à 16 ans ça
c'est MEUR de plus de 15 ans c'est ça
euh